NARRATOR: In a remote
atoll near Tahiti,
Kori Garza, Andy Casagrande,
and safety diver [inaudible]
put themselves in
the line of fire.
These investigators
test the theory
that some tiger sharks may work
together and hunt in packs.
Before they know
it, they're fending
off a double approach by two
large tiger sharks, and more.
Again and again, the sharks
seem to come in waves.
It's too much.
They must retreat.
ANDY CASAGRANDE: Hello.
That was--
That was intense.
I mean, there were pretty
insane moments on that camera.
ANDY CASAGRANDE: I saw you
deflecting one coming here,
another one behind you.
And then at one point
you appeared literally
like dancing on tigers.
It was crazy, huh?
KORI GARZA: You see what I
mean, how they all disappeared?
And then instead of
just like one coming in,
it's boom, all at once.
Here we go, 360 tiger sharks.
NARRATOR: They review the
footage and search for clues.
If these tigers
cooperatively hunt,
it may suggest that great
whites could also do the same.
KORI GARZA: Look at that.
ANDY CASAGRANDE: Oh, wow.
KORI GARZA: Oh, wow.
Oh, there are--
ANDY CASAGRANDE: One, two.
KORI GARZA: --three tigers.
ANDY CASAGRANDE: There's
three right there.
And that other tiger--
KORI GARZA: Just keeps
following, swimming around.
ANDY CASAGRANDE:
Following that tiger.
KORI GARZA: Yeah, he's
following that one.
They come in in a fleet.
NARRATOR: After careful review,
Kori is convinced, tiger sharks
working together makes sense.
KORI GARZA: It's better
for them and easier
for them to learn
to cooperate, rather
than to spend their whole
time fighting each other.
NARRATOR: It could
be an anomaly,
unique to this species,
except for emerging
evidence from around the world.
From sand tiger sharks
off South Africa
to lemon sharks in Australia,
and gray reefs in French
Polynesia, they've
all been observed
to seemingly work together.
And now this for the
tigers of Tahiti.
ANDY CASAGRANDE:
This 360 shows us
that all of the
sharks in mass are
showing up together
and leaving together,
pretty much every single time.
KORI GARZA: Every single time.
It's not, and this
is not coincidence.
ANDY CASAGRANDE: This
isn't coincidence.
Yeah, because it's
happening every single time.
[bubbles]
[music playing]